hi bill Corry here from Vermont
beautiful state of Vermont I'm a huge
fan by the way thank you for everything
that you do so my one question to you is
I've been reading a lot of things about
spirituality and electric impulses you
know really I guess stemming through our
entire Anatomy and kind of the concept
that our universe is us and we our
universe a little out there I get it I
know my question is to you what do you
think about that thank you
Cory this is a great question we in the
skeptical community are very skeptical
that there's any life force running
through us other than chemical energy
that makes us go now give you an example
yoga people do a lot of yoga and the big
thing in yoga is to stay flexible to
stretch to make sure your your bones and
muscles are stay limber and through your
whole life and it's very effective and
people get a lot out of it but along
that line there are claims that you have
these sources of energy in your body
that my understanding are called chakras
but no one has been ever able to observe
a chakra I mean there's an idea and you
might have it in your you might
experience it in your mind but there's
nobody who's been able to cut open a
human x-ray or a mouse and x-ray a human
tap on a human listen to a human with a
stethoscope but I'll take human blood
Sam and detect a chakra just hasn't
happened
with that said people people get a lot
of comfort out of communities to know
that other people are thinking the same
way you're thinking and and that there's
a team essentially the human team we'd
all work together push came to shove
excuse me
but I'm very skeptical that there's this
lie
force that runs through us all people
have gone looking for it from a
scientific standpoint for centuries now
remember there's a couple ideas in
science that are very important and
they're described nowadays and what's
called critical thinking your ability to
think critically about everything and
you cannot prove a negative in other
words if someone says you can't show
that there aren't chakras you can't show
that there isn't a lifeforce you can't
prove that I am not part of the
spirituality of the universe the spirit
of the universe and that's true you
can't prevent it's just a nature of
negative ideas of nots so with that said
the other idea in critical thinking is
skeptical thought is it's based on
claims or assertions or hypotheses that
you have to test so if you if somebody
makes a claim that there's a life force
flowing through him or her or through
all of us how would you go about proving
that how would you show that it's true
how would you show before and after
before the life force after the life
force with the life force without the
life force and you can say well after
somebody's dead they have no life force
okay but after somebody's dead they
would be dead whether there's a life
force or not so that aside there is a
lot in the universe that we don't know
what it is I'll give you that
furthermore there's dark energy dark
matter 96 95 percent of the universe
nobody knows what it is but I don't
think that's what you're talking about
you're talking about this in the
skeptical community right now it's
called whoo or woo woo the unknown that
flows through is the life energy but it
hasn't been proven so you can't prove a
negative you have to have something you
can test a claim these are very
important ideas in critical thinking in
science and I'm really glad you're
thinking about them because maybe you
will make a discovery that will change
the world give you an example nobody
knows exactly what consciousness is like
I'm thinking I'm thinking about thinking
I'm thinking about what you're thinking
you asked a question having to do with
what you were thinking what I'm thinking
when everybody's thinking but what is it
to have an idea what what is it when we
are aware of ourselves when we look in
the mirror we see ourselves what is
consciousness and this to me is very
reasonable it's related to this feeling
that Yoga people get when they talk
about this energy they feel this
lifeforce furthermore there's a lot of
people who study neuroscience talk about
the brain but they also talk about the
central nervous system the CNS and that
would be your brain connected to
everything else and one of the things
they liked it too are two of the things
they like to talk about it your eyes
your eyes are so intimately connected to
your brain that people like to say your
eyes are the only part of your brain
that you can see ah whoa dude but here's
an interesting study that has been
replicated many times if you are though
they'll set up psychiatrists or
psychologists will set up an experiment
where somebody comes into the room and
the Sun you the subject has to walk
toward them to do some interaction hand
them something then there'll be another
experiment where you have to move away
from him or her well if you move toward
them your tendency is to like that other
people better than if you're required to
move away from them so they set up a
test so that these two ideas are
independent that what you're trying to
accomplish and moving toward that person
are independent of whether or not you're
moving going this way or that way and
the expression that's popular right now
is embodied cognition this is to say
something you do with your central
nervous system commanding my hand to
move towards your way is somehow affects
what you feel like your brain and the
rest of your nervous system are not
independent so
when you move towards somebody you like
him or her more if you move away you
like him or her less by a little bit by
a measurable repeatable amount so it
could be that this idea of spirituality
and this life force that's flowing to us
through us this perception of that is
actually a manifestation or a result of
your central central nervous system and
your brain being all one piece and you
can't do this without affecting that
it's cool idea maybe you'll become a
neuroscientist and figure it out and
dare I say it
Corie change the world cool question